gente que se preocupa por todo el ser
humano
[Aplausos]
tenemos en nuestras manos en nuestro
poder
el poder de cambiar el presidente un
presidente que en medio de una situación
con muchas muertes proporciones
similares a las de la segunda guerra
mundial presidente
que no tiene sentido en accesibilidad en
vez de bailar alguien que es
presidente obama que trató de lograr el
acta de la salud tratamos de construir a
partir de ahí no destruyamos
you waiting
quiere que las personas
nos dicen a conocer quién soy yo de ti
yo país en conocer sobre dientes de
cáncer
y por supuesto
yo entiende estas situaciones y él dice
que tenemos que extenderlo tenemos que
bajar los costos de los premios los
costos de la salud tenemos que aumentar
la legibilidad para el medicare a partir
de la edad de los 60 años luego entiende
que cuando hablamos de la salud
que esto va a empezar una revolución
desde el primer día la salud es el
primer paso
la elección
el poder
en pertenece a nosotros a las personas
esta crisis ya ha estado de michigan
eso ha pasado desde hace mucho tiempo
estamos observando a eeuu
en los últimos meses más de 39 mil
personas
hay personas que están parqueadas en
filas buscando alimentos hay niños
menores de 12 años estarán vientos y
tantas personas creo que las cifras son
una persona de seis que están
describiendo que no son capaces de pagar
la renta y um puede que no la paguen el
próximo mes
y yo entiende toda esa situación
luego entiende que puedes mejorar la
economía eso de olivencia
pero quiere sacar
un alivio fiscal que solamente protege
al 1% como ayudar es eeuu
cuando yo pregunta como de la economía
yo dice
bueno yo pregunta cómo está la gente
trabajadora cómo les está yendo a ellos
cómo están las familias trabajadores
eso es lo que yo dice no estamos
presentando no presentan ningún
impuestos para personas que ganen menos
de 400 mil dólares al año yo dice que
vamos a bajar los impuestos a la clase
media hay un dice que vamos a probar
legislación
leyes que permitan a las familias
que impida que pague más de 7 por ciento
de su ingreso anual vamos a hacer un
impuesto fiscal
un crédito para ayudarle a las familias
a obtener dinero para comprar una casa
con un pago inicial
vamos a fortalecer la clase medio no
entiende cómo se hace eso uno lucha uno
protege
a los trabajos
la gente de los sindicatos es muy bueno
estar en michigan
tenemos una elección aquí en frente a
nuestro
el poder es en nuestras manos
piensen
el reconocimiento de vido y siempre
postergado a la injusticia racial en
eeuu
y yo siendo un estudiante de la historia
estadounidense
tiene el coraje de hablar y enfrentar
y apoya la black lips matters
[Aplausos]
yo entiendo puede que sea difícil pensar
hablar bueno escuchar pero tenemos que
confrontar la verdad de las cosas
tenemos que lidiar con la disparidad
racial en nuestro sistema criminal y en
una serie de situaciones incluyendo la
discriminación de la marihuana expandir
los derechos de la gente que ha estado
en cárcel por ofensas relaciones con
marihuana
gente que no puede pagar unas cuentas
por salud no pueden evolucionar y tener
en la cárcel yo no entiende de estas
cosas yo entiende que sobre el coaching
como los estados estadounidenses latinos
y afro-estadounidenses son tres veces
más posibles de obtenerla pero yo quiere
cambiar esto vamos a cambiar el récord
no queremos que la gente muera que se
acerca de morir en el nacimiento de joe
tiene el coraje de hablar de esas
situaciones hay elecciones claras en
frente de nosotros
así que hoy es bueno el día de
elecciones en eeuu
[Aplausos]
hoy es un día que muchos de nosotros
hemos estado esperando por cuatro años
tienen imaginado eso
y estamos muy comprometidos
y ahora sabemos
sabemos que está en nuestro poder he
estado viajando por todo el país y ni
siquiera puedo decirles señores dónde
podemos estar bueno estado de georgia en
florida en cabina del norte
en todo el país ohio pennsylvania
realmente fallar en todo el país y hay
algo que quiero decir porque ese es un
grupo de líderes ustedes no estarían
aquí en este parque si no fuera así
todos ustedes a ustedes les han pedido
lo que a mí me han pedido estoy seguro
que ha pasado parte de esas personas que
les dicen por qué debería votar les han
preguntado eso yo creo que tres razones
por las cuales la gente debería votar
una es
que tenemos que lidiar con el hecho
de que hay que honrar a nuestros
ancestros honremos a nuestros ancestros
perdimos
bueno
a un colega el gran congresista joe
louis
un granero estadounidense que derramó su
sangre en el puente félix por nuestro
derecho a votar hay que honrar a
nuestros ancestros hay que honrar el
hecho de que celebramos el aniversario
número 100 de la enmienda 19 el derecho
de una mujer a votar
[Aplausos]
todas estas mujeres vestidas de blanco
marchan lo gritando diciendo que no
querían ser silenciadas y que no los
quitan abc derecho pero nos cambiaran
simplemente dijeron la verdad fue 1965
hay que lidiar con ese hecho
en primer lugar los accesos en segundo
lugar
todo está en juego todo este juego
todo lo que hemos discutido el futuro de
nuestras escuelas públicas y joey yo
sabemos que hay que lidiar con las
escuelas de título 1 las comunidades
como abajo ingreso que tienen las
mayores necesidades
ellos necesitan mayor cantidad de
recursos para respaldarlos replicaremos
eso yo y yo decimos que es necesario que
se pague de la misma manera
y dice que es necesario lidiar con el
tema de manera el resaltó todas las
disparidades que han existido y debemos
tener una sociedad donde todos los
trabajadores reciban
pólizas por enfermedades sabemos que
todo está en riesgo incluyendo el futuro
de nuestra democracia
la razón número 3 para votar
viajar en este país déjeme decirles
todos ustedes posiblemente no lo sabían
el tipo de intentos que se están
haciendo para dificultarle a la gente
votar hacer que sea confuso yo estuve en
texas y en texas posible ser escuchado
lo que están haciendo y me entristece
decir que el condado harris
pero no suela justicia soy dijeron que
solamente tenían bueno urnas o una urna
en ese condado hay cuatro millones de
personas y una sola urna
posiblemente lo vieron en la noticias y
hay solamente una estación para votar
manejando en todo un condado derechos en
otros lugares bueno digamos si uno va a
votar por el correo tiene que llenar
bueno el tarjetón meterlo en un o en un
sobre lo comentan el otro hacer que una
persona firme luego que otra persona lo
firme
meterse con la oficina postal es decir
la oficina postal
la gente más amable trabaja en la
oficina postal
estableciéndose con oficina postal
entonces hay que preguntarse
porque tantas personas poderosas
están haciendo un esfuerzo tan grande
para hacer que sea tan difícil y confuso
que nosotros votemos y yo creo que
conocemos la respuesta es porque ellos
saben
de nuestro poder sabes de nuestro poder
saben que cuando votamos las cosas
cambian
saben que cuando votamos nosotros
ganamos
así que no permitamos que nadie nunca
nos quite de nuestro poder no permitamos
que nos silencio y nos permitamos que
nos engañen que no nos echen a un lado
en esta elección
hay muchos razones para hacer que todos
salgan a las urnas
a qué horas cierran a las 8 de la noche
entonces asegurémonos de que todos los
que conozcamos voten sigamos texteando
sigamos llamando tocando puertas de los
vecinos de los miembros de las familias
tenemos todo el día para hacer que esto
pase si estás bien en si una molesta a
la gente ellos lo van a superar y luego
nos agradecerán todos ellos volverán
pero ahora hay que mantenerse encima de
la situación porque está la situación
esta es mi única mi última afirmación
este momento pasará
de aquí en a varios años de esos hijos y
nuestros nietos
mirarán a nuestros ojos cada uno de
ellos y nos preguntarán
donde estaba en ustedes
en ese momento
y lo que queremos poder decirles
es mucho más que cómo nos sentimos en
ese momento lo que les vamos a decir es
lo que hicimos
[Aplausos]
les diremos
porque estábamos en un parqueadero
y organizándonos que estamos
movilizándonos que estábamos texteando
llamando tocando puertas les diremos que
estábamos con gary peters
aunque estamos con un grupo increíble
que estamos haciendo todo lo posible
saben que más les diremos cuando ellos
pregunten les diremos
que elegimos a joe biden
como presidente de los eeuu muchas
gracias a todos
[Aplausos]